streaming has revolutionized the music
industry but for whose benefit artists
now struggle to earn the same living as
performers that made their fortunes from
cds and vinyl sales judge jules was once
hailed as the best dj in the world he's
also a music lawyer he thinks a good
grasp of the law is key for a prosperous
future in the industry
judge jules thanks for joining me on the
show today now you're known as one of
the world's biggest djs
i know you
from my youth uh and watching you and
listening to you but for those people
out there that perhaps don't know you
they might be a bit younger than us
um can we start with why you're actually
called judge jules
i was i got into djing by promoting
events when i was
16 and
the the the best time to start promoting
really is when you're that young because
what you don't realize when you're 16 is
that's when you've got the biggest
social circle you're ever going to have
in your life and of course with each
passing five years
your social circle halves and when you
reach my age by this point it's almost
non-existent but the good thing was i
was putting on uh events
at that age many of them were illegal
events and i should probably point out
that illegal then was a lot less illegal
than it now is because the laws were
subsequently tightened up yeah
and when we were promoting those illegal
events the police came to the door they
thrust innocent 18 year old dj jules to
the door to say
and i was a law student at the time
and
basically told the police this is for me
and my law student chums officer and
that from there came the name of the
judge i'm not a real judge i should have
hated to add but in my mind in my mind's
eye i am anyway
you became a
a lawyer
you did a law degree
but you were also a studious boy from
north london right you sort of had a
twin track life is that
fair to say i think i think there are
quite a lot of people in the music
business who do come out with a degree
and have a sort of educated background i
don't think i was the only person in
that environment but we were part when i
was 16 to 21 we were part of a sort of
collective if you like that put on raves
that's what we did a couple of us were
at university a couple of us
probably came from families where nobody
had ever been in in any generation to
university but that was the kind of fun
thing we were just we were doing it for
all the right reasons because we
absolutely loved what we did we loved
the music we were supporting and they
didn't and the music we were supporting
didn't really have any outlet you lost
your mum when you were 18 years old
that's incredibly young to lose your
your mum and i'm sorry and i i lost my
mum so i know how rough it is did that
kind of change your outlook you know did
it did it kind of
change your view about how you wanted to
live your life or the risks you wanted
to take maybe i think i think i think it
had two i it had one um one impact that
only realized quite a long time
afterwards which was
the the healing power of music i um
it's funny because when during the
pandemic i started doing live streams i
did probably about i've done about 100
live streams i'm still doing them
periodically now and whereas when you go
out on dj you might have a few beers and
you might sort of be a little bit tipsy
when you do a live stream you're
completely
stone cold sober and i was getting such
a buzz out of doing these live streams
and it was that that was my eureka
moment wow music was what really helped
me through what was quite a traumatic
time in my life and then of course the
other thing i think you would get the
same answer out of anybody who loses a
parent early it makes you realize it
might all be gone tomorrow it makes you
realize the finality of life and
um it sort of kicks you into action
arguably faster than it would for others
who have a
slightly less sorry tale to tell at that
a similar age you are the first
generation of celebrity djs you were
voted the best dj in the world
let's just pause and enjoy that in 1995
by the dj mag
what was it about the late 80s and 90s
that gave rise to this
particular phenomena of the world famous
dj what was it about that time was it
quite a magical time it was a magical
time i mean it was uh it's i i suppose
what changed everything and i don't want
to sound like a luddite because the
internet or high-speed internet
in many ways has has been the ultimate
um
propagator of all things artistic yeah
but before high-speed uh internet the
only way that you could discover this
incredible music this incredible vibe
was via a limited amount of touch points
which was kind of a handful of magazines
record shops which specialist record
shops
a couple of shows on radio one and of
course these super clubs that existed in
many even quite small cities throughout
the uk
and i've always thought that the one
thing about clubbing stroke festival
culture is it's almost like the last
bastion of an opportunity to hang out
with people you don't know in a kind of
semi
for the most part a very safe
environment and jules the the dance
music scene back then as we both know
was strongly associated to with hedonism
with partying of course with illegal
with illegal drugs
looking at you you are definitely not
one of those who are the casualty of
hard living may i say you're looking
very good
um was it unusual to stay removed from
all of that aspect of the lifestyle or
was it more common than maybe people
thought like you could be involved but
you didn't have to kind of partake in
the heavy drug taking yeah i think the
heart i think the hard party and
sometimes dare i say it is in the in the
people who hang around you know whether
whether they're djs or whether they're
musicians it's often the people who are
hanging around them rather than the
artists themselves because it's
the life yeah the life
it's a job but it's a it's a job that
you're being paid to do something that
you would willingly pay others to let
you do but at the same time you know
it's a very hardcore existence i was
doing
two 200 250 shows a year probably 200
flights a year i still do not far shy of
that now but
going around the world doing a long haul
trip every every
fortnight which sounds like a on the one
hand it's the dr you know a school boys
dream on the other hand you simply
couldn't be absolutely sort of
battered and bruised and do that it just
wouldn't work as it got more difficult
for musicians and artists to earn a
living because of
streaming and because of the way in
which the industry's changing it's got
more difficult to make a career for
yourself sticking your head above the
parapet is
has never been more difficult now there
are between sixty thousand and seventy
thousand spotify releases a day
so you've gotta be an all-round um
here you've got a business savvy uh
making good records just isn't enough
just on this ed sheeran was recently
awarded 900 000 pounds in legal for a
very high profile case after winning
that copyright tar in which he and two
of his co-writers were accused of
plagiarizing part of a song called oy by
a relatively unknown artist sammy switch
where did your sympathies lie in that
case
it's very difficult because you i mean
one thing that you as a lawyer you need
to understand that a a copyright
infringement case has a has a lot of
different layers it has
expert opinion it has obviously what the
judges do
on the one hand there is a there is an
increasing culture of
creatives um screaming plagiarism uh
both in copyright and in other areas of
intellectual property yeah um and it's a
good thing if the bar is set a little
bit higher to prevent dare i say it's
sort of lawyers working on no win no fee
on a no win no fee basis agreeing to act
on the behalf of people screaming blue
murder
on the other you do feel for you know
the little guy who's suddenly gonna
stump up a huge amount of legal fees do
you think that case was avoidable then
do you think that case shouldn't have
come to court
my my in my view no if if i listen to
the two the two songs
it's it's an ever moving feast and there
isn't really a right or wrong answer in
fact on the sky i commented a few times
um when that when that case was
was adjudicated but no in that
particular case no
let's just move on to politics um
a massive unforeseen challenge in face
by the industry
was the pandemic
and covid how how was that for you was
it really difficult covert was difficult
for me but much more difficult for my
peers because i've got this this dual
life my legal practice was very strong
many of my peers fell through the cracks
because
a lot of people in the creative industry
were advised by their accountants to set
up your own small business and pay
yourself in dividends that was the the
stock accountant's advice to not just
musicians just about everybody now if
that's the way you paid yourself you got
zero support from the government right
and even though a lot of people were
crying out to richie sunak to do
something about it he never did i want
to ask you about one of your former
colleagues
dj tim westwood he's been accused of
sexual misconduct between 1992 and 2017
something which tim westwood has denied
this week the bbc revealed it did
receive complaints about alleged sexual
misconduct and bullying by the dj one
which was referred to the police
when you saw those reports which you
know tim westwood did it surprise you
i wouldn't i i don't know tim wester
well enough to know whether any of it is
true or not but to to learn that the bbc
denied ever having received complaints
and now it has been discovered that
there were not just one but a number of
complaints is a really bad look for the
bbc a really bad look so i i i don't
feel sort of qualified either legally or
morally to comment on what tim westwood
did because i simply don't know but it
but this does not reflect well on the
bbc that's for sure what you think the
bbc have potentially been involved in a
cover-up
well with due to freedom of information
they're they're a public body for whom
freedom of information applies they were
never going to be able to cover it up it
seems
either very incompetent or a cover-up
i guess the question would be then given
that you weren't there
was there a sort of culture like that
during at the bbc during the time you
were there do you think or back in that
period of time did you witness that did
you ever pick that up no i would say
quite the opposite actually i thought
but then i was at the bbc immediately
after jimmy savile
well not after the jimmy savile stuff
happened but after it came out i was i
started on the bbc two a couple of years
later
and
that so if anything there was a really
proactive attempt to be inclusive to not
allow that to happen so it's
disappointing that um
the similar stories have occurred but
again i don't want to sort of cast
aspersions on what did or didn't happen
no what do you think the bbc should do
about it now
there's going to be serious internal
questions asked about how
it was said in the first instance
whenever it was a couple of months ago
that there had that nothing had occurred
when there is such a
when the proof of the pudding has been
discovered so soon afterwards um
something has gone very wrong how the
decision-making worked in the upper
echelons of the bbc i don't know but
questions i mean it sounds like a very
vague answer but questions certainly
need to be asked okay thank you very
much thanks for joining me i really
enjoyed that and
have fun in ibiza